all right we are back with the Fox News
Alert we have just learned this British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson has tested
positive for the coronavirus trait yanks
joins us live from our Jerusalem bureau
with more Trey the Prime Minister just
spoke about it right Ainsley Bryan Steve
good morning that's right we are just
learning now that UK prime minister
Boris Johnson has tested positive for
coronavirus this announced earlier today
by Downing Street and the prime minister
himself releasing a statement saying
this quote I am now self isolating but I
will continue to lead the government's
response via videoconference as we fight
this virus Johnson's condition is
apparently well he is only displaying
mild symptoms according to Downing
Street all of this just hours after
Boris Johnson participated in a g20
summit call with world leaders leaders
including President Trump that call
yesterday Johnson at pledging 210
million pounds to develop a vaccine for
coronavirus all of this coming as
Johnson has now committed to fighting
this inside the UK we do know that
there's currently more than 11,000 cases
in the United Kingdom with more than 600
dead I do want you to take a listen to
what Johnson had to say earlier today
regarding this positive diagnosis I've
developed mild symptoms of the corona
virus that's to say a temperature and a
persistent cough and on the advice of
the chief medical officer I've taken a
test that has come out positive so I am
working from the home and self isolating
and that's entirely the right thing to
do Prime Minister Johnson does join
Prince Charles who tested positive when
it comes to the list of notable Brits
who are now fighting this battle
personally when you look at the broader
perspective for the United Kingdom right
now in London they are converting a
large Expo Centre to a makeshift field
hospital we do understand that more than
500 hospital beds are going to be put
into this Center in an effort to try to
slow the spread of corona virus in the
United Kingdom we can't expect some
criticism
for Johnson today who early on had some
policy differences with some of his top
advisors about how exactly the United
Kingdom should approach the Battle of
this virus but again what we can confirm
today is that the United Kingdom Prime
Minister Boris Johnson has tested
positive for Carano virus he will
continue to lead the efforts in the UK
to fight this Co bid 19 disease as it
does continue to spread in countries
around the world looking to work
together to clamp down and find a
vaccine